who doesn't love a good old slugfest
hand-to-hand combat i feel is quite
underrated in the realm of anime and
then again why wouldn't it be when
you've got some world ending powers and
magic that anime tend to show still
there's just something in hand to hand
combat that elicits such strong
reactions with each blow either out of
amazement at the animation or the
emotions being shown by the characters
today we'll be talking about some of my
favorite anime that heavily features
some hand-to-hand combat fights magical
powers aren't exempt but i will try to
focus on stuff that features more
physical close quarters battles
ah it's been a while hitori noshita is
one of those underrated gems that went
under the radar despite having aired for
quite a while well it's hard to stand
out in an anime season and the nature of
the source material didn't really help
matters in such an underdog position the
best bet you can make is to excel at
something and hitori noshita did just
that where where else for a show that
heavily features hand-to-hand combat but
the godly animation i featured this show
a couple of times on my top fight list
due to how smooth and fluid these
battles look one i think emotional
investment for those fights isn't as
high for me the actual motion and
spectacle of people punching each other
and doing martial arts feels like a
miracle in itself especially if you look
at the latest season if you haven't
watched hitori noshita you should try
picking it up sometime soon i feel it's
a fun action series that deserves quite
a bit more love it's got four seasons
currently but it shouldn't be too hard
to catch up on
we resume with webcomics superiority
with the next entry god of high school
it felt like yesterday when everyone was
filled with hype god of high school's
first episode dropped and it pretty much
stole a thunder from a season filled
with big sequels that included stuff
like snafu and the original storyline of
sao oh and there's a re-zero season
airing too but no everyone's attention
was on god of high school well if you
watch the first episode and see how it
dazzles you with the fighting than you'd
understand i find it sad that the show
got rushed but when it comes down to the
one thing it does well it does very very
well god of high school has some of the
best and most hyped fights i've seen in
modern anime and it bodes well for the
show that has an identity of being that
korean battle tournament anime god of
high school has since earned a polarized
reputation but if you're up for some
awesome fight after awesome fight then
you've definitely come to the right
place fog hill of five elements is next
on the list
we come back to yet another
underappreciated gem largely due to the
same reasons as hitori no noshita it's
shows like these that make me happy that
i spent quite some time scouring through
the whole roster of anime that gets
produced every season from various
corners of asia it makes me feel my
efforts are worth it when i stumble upon
these treasures four killer five
elements like hitori noshita makes up
for a lack of exposure and hype by
putting its eggs in the basket of
eye-catching fights as during the
latter's modern setting foghill takes us
to the ancient era of kingdoms and
mysticism it's got some amazing
sequences that i've talked about in a
video before and you should definitely
check that one out to get a glimpse of
what to expect this is a short three
episode title so if you've got time over
the weekend you should definitely give
it a shot it's not a huge time
investment and if you like these kind of
settings with elements of martial arts
and history i guarantee you're gonna end
up loving this one
[Music]
we resume with megalo box
and here comes mr action anime of 2018.
oh you don't know who that is well
there's this other video i made where
under certain qualifiers are crowned
megalo box action anime of its year it's
unique in terms of aesthetics in a
sports anime and is filled to the brim
with gritty and intense fights surely a
call back to the good old days of ashita
no joe and the like megalo box combines
the western feel with sci-fi sport and a
whole lot of drama and emotion as i said
in that video it evoked a sense of
nostalgia for me and it could do so for
you too the fights might not be as
flashy as something from any of the
three mentioned shows on the list but
the emotion and the impact are things
that not a lot of anime can replicate so
make sure you check out megalo box
while we're on the topic of boxing anime
we can now move on with hajime no ippo
nothing beats the og the original the
king of combat sports anime hajime no
ippo has been met with critical acclaim
thanks to its immersive story
progression lovable characters and
mostly the fights that go beyond
expectations hajime no ippo is one of
the most honest sports anime out there
and in spite of lacking much of the
flair and superpowers that sports anime
often employ it's carved a legacy for
itself in the history of anime it's no
surprise that the show will have lots of
intense fights that really make you feel
the blood sweat and tears that these
athletes go through in their race to
eternal glory most takamura fights
should be a good starting point for
battle enthusiasts but ippo himself has
a lot of those amazing battles as well
what i like about hajime no ippo is that
it's not entirely about sport the
characters the world and such all have
their fair share of development and i'd
say that among sports anime this show is
probably the most complete among them
all
and hey if you've been enjoying the
video so far that subscribe button is
looking real appealing now i bet isn't
it if you're one of those many people
watching and haven't subscribed then
please consider doing so seeing that
subscriber count go up is one of the
biggest motivators for any content
creator after all right have you done
subscribing good thank you for your
patronage let's get back to the video
real drive is up next and this one's a
banger
this is a show that hasn't been talked
about that much real drive takes a lot
of inspiration from the cyberpunk series
of all that has quite the psychosocial
or metaphysical backdrop think something
like ghost in the shell or even serial
experiments lane if we're to stretch out
even further while real drive didn't get
away from the popularity that those
mentioned titles enjoyed it does have
one very special thing going for it
awesome hand-to-hand combat fights you
should check those out if you want to
find a reason to pick up this show
combat enthusiasts would surely enjoy
the show and i hope that whichever type
of watcher you are you'll definitely
give this niche series a shot it takes a
while to rev up and all but i had a
blast watching it from start to finish
[Music]
how can we have a list featuring
hand-to-hand combat anime without barky
[Music]
of course barky takes a spot on this
list honestly bucky doesn't have the
most original premise out there young
man goes on a journey to become the
strongest person in the world however
the show makes up for an execution
thanks to its wild cast of characters
that are full of crazy out of this world
surprises barky's become quite the cult
classic it's a show that i admire for
being on point with its goal as well no
slice of life shenanigans here none of
the comedic moments you've likely come
to expect if you're an avid fan of
modern anime just straight up brutal and
intense fighting all throughout it's not
like god of high school where the plot's
pacing has been completely sacrificed in
favor of the flashy fights baki has a
pretty damn solid progression as well
with characters that are pretty fleshed
out this makes you want to follow
everyone's journey and dig deep into
their motivations baki's become my
poster child for the saying with the
proper execution there's nothing that's
too wild or crazy to work and i guess
that statement stands given the audience
reception for the show and it's modern
sequels
i intentionally placed baki and gengar
are still right next to each other
because honestly speaking the two do
have a lot in similar both are fighting
anime with journey arcs both have the
same vibes in terms of fights and both
are as brutal and intense as each other
heck i wouldn't be surprised if gengar
ashura ended up being inspired by baki
people have criticized gengar ashura for
the cg but i personally don't think it
detracts from it too much i mean it's
not berserk tear or god forbid ari
firethat i think that despite the cg the
anime still manages to capture the real
important things for a fighting anime
the emotional impact of the actual
fights and the characters who all come
in fighting for something he had a
somewhat slow start but picks up pretty
quickly and while the plot does seem
straightforward i myself thoroughly
enjoyed it it's available on netflix if
you're up for some viciously passionate
fights
i want to end this list with something
most of you are familiar with and i
think the best mainstream anime for it
would be naruto
naruto is one of the shows that spawned
an entire generation of fans i know i
know hand-to-hand combat's not the first
thing you think of when we say naruto
however in that batch of mainstream
shonen that took over in the 2000s is
the one that emphasized combat
specifically had to hand combat the most
well you just got to look at how awesome
rockley's major fights were despite
largely being comic relief he and guy
have some of the most memorable fights
that made our childhood and of course
who could forget that gargashi vs obito
fight naruto's a show featuring ninjas
that barely act like actual ninjas and
come equipped with demon beasts magical
eyes and the like but all that craziness
doesn't overshadow those epic moments of
physical hand-to-hand combat i can still
record how awesome it was when guy out
of all people gave madhura a run for his
money naruto's had a long run and it's a
journey that i don't regret taking it's
a long runner but if you're up for a
long-running shonen with a lot of
awesome hand-to-hand fights while having
so many people to talk to about it then
naruto is a personal favorite and my top
recommendation
so how about you which anime with the
best hand-to-hand combat fights is your
favorite it could be something from my
list or better yet something that i
neglected to mention i'd be very happy
to see what you've got for me so give it
your best shot on the comment section
down there as always be sure to stay a
little bit longer and browse the channel
in case you see a video that catches
your attention i've got a lot of content
and you might just find the perfect one
that you've been looking for you may
also support me through channel
memberships and patreon and you can help
grow my instagram community too it would
make me very happy and i'll continue
bringing you some anime or channel
related news there that's it for today
hope you had fun and i'll see you in the
next one
[Music]